c'est un des métros les plus achalandées
du monde il n'est pas écarté de le
fermer dans quelques jours si pour
l'instant moscou désinfecte les wagons
plusieurs écoles sont encore ouverts qui
ce n'est que demain que la russie
fermera la porte aux étrangers jusqu'au
1er mai dans les aéroports les contrôles
sont donc plus sévère que jamais et
c'est ici dans un hôpital en banlieue de
moscou que tous les voyageurs soupçonné
d'être véritablement malade sont placés
en isolement
nous avons pu filmer des gens arriver
directement l'aéroport valises en
maîtres l'art inquiets avant d'être
testé nos soirées où beaucoup pour
gagner grâce à des mesures préventives
que la situation est sous contrôle a
déclaré aujourd'hui le président poutine
en visitant le nouveau centre de
contrôle et de surveillance contre le
coran navires russes à moscou la russie
a pu contenir la propagation massive dit
il de trop mais à vrai dire personne ne
sait ce qui se passe réellement dans les
hôpitaux avec le coronavirus dit la
docteure anastasia vassilieva qui est
président de l'alliance des médecins
elle est convaincue que des milliers de
personnes sont infectées au pays avec ou
sans diagnostic et elle n'est pas là ce
un autre médecin qui nous avons parlé et
qui ne veut pas être nommé nous a dit
que beaucoup d'entre eux ne rapporte
plus les cas suspects aux autorités pour
d'abord éviter que leurs cliniques
soient fermées et que leurs patients
soient pris en charge par l'état dans
des conditions est désirable
m la docteure vassilieva parle
d'ailleurs d'un manque criant de
ressources et de main d'oeuvre et a dit
avoir entendu de ses collègues aux
quatre coins du pays que les résultats
des tests de dépistage quand ils sont
administrés ne sont pas toujours
communiquer aux patients
et selon le professeur et scientifique
valérie sol et v les médecins subissent
d'immenses pressions pour modifier les
causes officielles des décès de
centaines de patients depuis la mi
janvier
selon ces informations
plus de mille décès causés par le
coronavirus aurait été attribué à la
pneumonie ou encore à des crises
cardiaques les autorités mans didier et
pour citer un autre médecin la russie
semble se rabattre sur l'immunité pas si
c'est à dire plus le virus circule plus
vite
il disparaîtra difficile dans les
circonstances de prédire la suite moscou
pour annoncer à son tour en isolement
total
même si président insiste pour dire que
son pays semble avoir évité
le site amaral de l'escaut radio-canada
ans